so I mean this has quite a long history
in that at the end of the 19th century a
guy called Edwin Abbott wrote a very
famous book called flatland in which he
kind of explored a flat universe it was
sort of social satire rather than
physics so he didn't go much into the
physics of the universe but subsequent
to that various people who looked at it
and most famously a guy called Alexander
dude nee who's a computer scientist in
Canada has gone through figuring out a
lot of the physics of what the universe
would look like if it actually only had
two dimensions whether you could
actually make it work on
Alexander jr. a book called the plain
universe in which he actually it's a
story about some people who accidentally
start kind of communicating with the
two-dimensional universe and so he kind
of explores the communication between
universes and so on but there's a load
of technical appendices at the end of
the book about what the science behind
it was and actually I read it you know
in the mid-1980s just after it came out
somebody gave it to me for Christmas and
I was fascinated by this is one of the
things that sort of inspired me about
physics and actually one of the things
that just sort of made me think the most
when I started doing this well it's
something very trivial if you were a
two-dimensional being living on a flat
piece of paper so your little stick
figure living on a stack Peaks flat
piece of paper and you try and lift one
end of a plank up you can't do it
because there's nowhere for the air to
rush in you're kind of creating a vacuum
by lifting the end of the plank because
you've got the plank resting on the
ground and then there's you holding onto
the plank so there's no gap there for
air to come in the way there is from the
sides in three dimensions so you can't
do it you can't even pick up a plank and
in fact in this book he had these
characters having to kind of shuffle
their feet up and down to sort of let
the air in as they were lifting one end
of things in order for that to happen so
it was just that trivial example got me
absolutely fascinated with these things
and there's all sorts of stuff like if
you start trying to think about biology
my supposing you have a two-dimensional
being if it had a digestive tract in
other words it has a mouth going all the
way down to the bottom then basically
it'll fall in half right because there's
nothing holding the two halves together
in two dimensions and so you have to
come up with some clever way if you want
your two dimensional beings to be able
to eat and not fall in half and so Judy
came up with this idea of basically a
zipper you can because you can have a
zipper in two dimensions and so these
creatures are kind of zipped together
and that allows things to kind of work
their way down through their bodies so
it's complicated world living in two
dimensions can you one more example that
one more good good thing so an
astronomical example astronomy in two
dimensions and space travel in two
dimensions turns out space travel in two
dimensions is quite tricky and that's
because there the concept of escape
velocity doesn't exist in in two
dimensions right that actually it turns
out that so on in three dimensions the
force of gravity drops off like 1 over
distance squared which means as you go
if you go twice as far away the force of
gravity is four times this week if you
go down the dimension so it's only two
dimensions it turns out that only
gravity only drops off like 1 over
distance so when you're twice as far
away gravity is still weaker but only by
a factor of two
rather than a factor of four so that
means gravity is a much longer range
force in two dimensions than it is in
three dimensions and so that means that
so in three dimensions there's this
concept of escape speed you can actually
fire a rocket fast enough from the earth
say and it can actually escape entirely
in two dimensions because the force of
gravity is that much stronger that much
longer range no matter how fast you fire
your rocket up into space it will
eventually always turn around and come
back and that means firstly that
actually you can't you know deep space
travel is very difficult right because
actually you have to put huge amounts of
energy in to get far enough to actually
get to the next planet but worse than
that it means that actually the universe
is sort of doomed because the entire
universe can't achieve escape velocity
either so the universe can't keep
expanding forever and will eventually
collapse back on itself and so there
will always be a big crunch in a two
dimensional universe a lot of people are
probably under the belief that our
universe is going to do that so well
life is complicated right firstly in our
universe in three dimensions it doesn't
have to happen in our universe there was
probably this thing called a
cosmological constant or dark energy
which is driving things apart so
actually when I started thinking about
this again for making this video I
started thinking couldn't you do the
same for a flat universe right if we
introduced this cosmological constant
would that actually allow the universe
to keep expanding forever
so I talked to my particle theory
colleagues who are much clever at these
kinds of things it turns out that
actually general relativity doesn't work
in two spatial dimensions that or at
least you can make it work but it's very
limited in that the concept of action at
a distance goes away in other words the
pull of gravity outside any body is zero
so actually you can't if you live in a
general relativistic universe you can't
even have gravitational interactions
between bodies the way we do in our
three dimensional three spatial
dimension or universe so if you believe
in general relativity
rather than Newtonian gravity which is
what I was just talking about then
actually you can't build a universe at
all with gravity in it or it's not
gravity in any way that we recognize it
so why why bother to do this probably
because it's kind of fascinating and
actually you know if you like you can
think of it as sort of an exercise for
scientist because it's good to kind of
think about things in ways you don't
usually think about things and that's
how you kind of try and do new science
it's trying to think about things in new
ways but it turns out actually there are
two dimensional things in the real
universe and the most current exam
is this stuff called graphene which is
this sort of single layer thickness of
carbon new new type of carbon that's
been discovered and it really does
behave because it's only a single layer
of atoms thick the electrons as they
move around within graphene are really
moving in two dimensions which means
that the physics of what's going on
really is explained in terms of two
dimensions so there are physical systems
that are real current research interests
where understanding the physics of what
goes on in two dimensions is really
important it's really stuck with me the
idea of these two dimensional beings
trying to eat and following her yes and
these other conundrums if there are
people who live in four spatial
dimensions
well they look at us and laugh in the
same way I should be other things about
us that are we're limited what are we
limited I I think they probably would
they would how on earth can you exist in
only three dimensions it's so
restrictive you know the number of
things you can do in three dimensions
here in four dimensions we can do all
sorts of clever things that they can't
do in three dimensions another thing in
if you start thinking about
two-dimensional and three-dimensional
beings is the the connections in the
brain because in three dimensions you
know it's quite easy to wire things up
and so you can actually wire all the
neurons together in two dimensions it's
actually a lot more complicated because
things have to cross over and you've got
to figure out how you can pass
information where wires cross over and
so on and so actually a
three-dimensional brain is probably
easier to design and probably can be
more efficient than the two-dimensional
brain now presumably if you went up into
four dimensions things will get even
more efficient because the number of
ways you can link things together gets
you know that much bigger and so
presumably you know a four dimensional
brain could be an awful lot clever and
the three-dimensional brain and they
will presumably pity us for our
miserable three dimensional thoughts
when they can have four-dimensional
thoughts I can't imagine how a fourth
spatial dimension works can no human
imagine that or is that my limitation
well that's that I mean in some ways
that's the lovely thing about thinking
about two dimensions because actually if
you start thinking about well how would
a two dimensional being think about
three dimensions that at least gives you
the beginning of an insight of how can
the three dimensional beings start to
think about four spatial dimensions but
there is no fourth spatial dimension
well if you ask the particle theorists
they can tell you that sometimes you
have eleven spatial dimensions but most
of them are very small but
no for practical purposes there are
three spatial dimensions that we know
following the earth around there used to
be lots of science fiction stories about
l-3 used to be a popular place to put
the anti earth or you know if you're an
evil genius that's where you put your
hidden lair because it was always hidden
behind the Sun as the two kind of orbit
around each other we've now had enough
satellites out there that have actually
looked at the other side of the solar
system to know actually there isn't
anything much at l3